madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
rapporteur à mon tour de m'associer au
dénonciation ferme à l'égard des menaces
dont vous avez été l'objet les violences
et menaces trop nombreuses à l'égard des
élus et des représentants du peuple
n'ont absolument pas leur place dans la
démocratie
nous sommes le 24 août
1837 dans un vacarme assourdissant et
une épaisse fumée le premier train de
voyageur s'élance de l'embarcadère de la
place de l'Europe aujourd'hui la gare
Saint-Lazare à son bord la reine
Marie-Amélie femme du roi Louis-Philippe
les 19 km entre Paris et Le Pecq sont
avalés en 28 minutes contre 2h30 en
diligence une révolution dans la
connexion entre les territoires et leurs
populations
le cheval est désormais concurrencé par
le cheval vapeur
malgré le succès de ce voyage inaugural
Adolphe Thiers déclara que le chemin de
fer n'était qu'un jouet pour parisien et
qu'on ne transporterait jamais un
voyageur ni même un seul bagage de cette
façon
185 ans plus tard nous avons pourtant
près de 28000 km de voies ferrées et
plusieurs millions de passagers
transportés chaque jour sur tout le
territoire
reste qu'il subsiste toujours des zones
insuffisamment couvertes où la voiture
individuelle qui a remplacé la diligence
reste la solution privilégiée ou subies
si les mobilités occupent une place
centrale dans le quotidien de nos
concitoyens avec près d'une heure par
jour passé en moyenne dans les
transports rien que pour le trajet
domicile-travail les trois quarts des
Français utilisent leur véhicule pour se
rendre au travail alors qu'un tiers de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont dus au transport il est bien
évidemment impératif que nous
accélérions sur la transition vers des
mobilités plus durables
c'est l'ambition de cette proposition de
loi qui favorise le développement des
services express régionaux métropolitain
pour offrir à nos concitoyens une
alternative à la voiture individuelle
est limitée les impacts négatifs sur
notre environnement car nos villes et
nos concitoyens ont suffoquent
l'objectif est clair doubler la part
modale du ferroviaire dans nos
déplacements du quotidien
renforcer les mobilités c'est non
seulement vivifier un territoire tout
entier mais c'est aussi réduire les
inégalités économiques et sociales en
favorisant l'insertion et les échanges
ces ambitions doivent se traduire en
acte concret cette proposition de loi
permet de partager le savoir-faire
précieux et reconnu de la Société du
Grand Paris avec les territoires
volontaires pour développer des services
express régionaux métropolitains et
ainsi qu'on courir un maillage fin du
territoire
c'est Ingénierie est un élément
indispensable à la bonne réalisation des
projets et à l'accélération du
développement du ferroviaire qui doit
agir comme une colonne vertébrale autour
de laquelle s'articuleont d'autres
mobilités propres c'est bien d'une
véritable offre multi modale dont il est
question qui doit être pensé dès la
conception des projets un impératif si
nous voulons offrir à nos concitoyens un
continuum de service qui répondent à
leurs attentes nous nous y trompons pas
c'est l'offre qui participe aussi à
créer la demande elle doit être
satisfaisante en termes de fréquence et
de fiabilité si l'une ou l'autre fait
défaut c'est l'assurance de son échec
les débats en commission ont permis de
soulever de nombreuses questions que ce
soit sur l'aspect technique la
gouvernance ou encore le financement des
réponses ont pu être apportées notamment
sur la définition du CERN sur
l'intégration de nouveaux objectifs ou
encore sur la clarification de
l'organisation et du partage des
compétences entre les différents acteurs
il reste cependant encore quelques
sujets sur lesquels nous souhaitons
apporter des évolutions complémentaires
le groupe démocrate défendra trois
amendements le premier sur
l'accessibilité les cernes doivent
favoriser l'accès de tous et notamment
des personnes en situation de handicap
qui ont trop souvent le sentiment d'être
assignés à résidence faute de moyens de
transport adaptés le deuxième sur
l'importance de ces RER métropolitain
dans le désenclavement des territoires
périls urbains comme ruraux personne ne
doit être laissé sans solution si nous
voulons lutter contre l'auto-solisme le
troisième pour garantir l'interopie
opérabilité des services d'information
voyageurs et de biotiques afin d'avoir
l'expérience la plus simple et fluide
possible c'est un gage de réussite
de nombreuses villes et élues sont
volontaires pour accélérer sur le
ferroviaire il nous faut leur garantir
des solutions pour les soutenir
résolument dans leur démarche cette
proposition de loi y participe et bien
évidemment le groupe démocrate la
soutiendra je vous remercie
merci